welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Cameron a professor of
political science at Yale University and
the director of the program in European
Union studies at the Macmillan Center
professor Cameron teaches courses on
European politics and the European Union
over the past year and a half the
members of the European Union that have
adopted the euro have been immersed in a
seemingly never-ending debt crisis first
grease then Ireland and Portugal and now
grease again as well as growing concerns
about Italy why do the crisis happen
where is it now and what can the EU do
welcome professor Cameron thank you
let's begin talking about what exactly
is a eurozone give us an overview the
eurozone is a group of seventeen members
of the European Union their 27 members
in all in the European Union the 17
members have agreed to give up control
of monetary policy turn it over to the
European Central Bank give up their
national currency exchange it for the
euro okay and those 17 countries got
into the eurozone by meeting certain
criteria set out in the treaty and
European Union that was signed in 1992
okay so we've had the eurozone since 92
basic well we've had the commitment to
go to european economic and monetary
union since 1992 the eurozone itself
started in nineteen ninety nine eleven
countries joined at that time Greece
joined two years later in 2001 and other
countries have joined since then so now
we have 17 in okay and why is this
crisis happening what's going on well
the crisis is happening it's essentially
a debt crisis
the countries in the euro zone are
supposed to keep their deficits at three
percent of GDP or less and they
committed to that in something called
the stability and growth pact that was
agreed in the 1990s just before the
eurozone began the country's haven't
done that the pact hasn't been enforced
there hasn't been compliance countries
have routinely exceeded those levels of
deficit who was supposed to be enforcing
it well that's the problem there isn't
anyone to enforce it Wow it's a question
of a slap on the wrist and public naming
and shaming but it's really there's
really no enforcement mechanism no real
sanctions so countries have simply
ignored it all of the countries have
ignored it at one time or another
including France and Germany as a result
countries have built up large amounts of
public debt okay now two years ago when
a new Greek government was elected in
october two thousand nine the new prime
minister at the time George Papandreou
announced that the deficit for Greece
wasn't what the previous government had
said five percent of GDP it would be
twelve point seven percent of GDP and he
said the previous government had
fabricated the results on the deficit
the markets got very anxious about this
because in 2010 Greece would have to
borrow over 50 billion euros in the
financial markets and it already had a
very high amount of debt okay is that
what kicked off the gods grace was the
first battle the problem okay and now
they find themselves in more trouble
what's going on now even more trouble
now because what happened last spring
sorry in the spring of 2010 is that
Greece realized it would have to
ro both from the EU and the IMF and
negotiated a 110 billion euro bailout
was the largest bailout that the IMF had
ever been involved in to finance itself
since it really couldn't go into the
markets and borrow because the markets
were demanding such a high rate of
interest given the risk oh sure that the
debt would the Greece would default so
one of the things that happens in in
that kind of borrowing packages a
country assumes responsibility to get
its fiscal house in order meaning
putting in some kind of deficit reducing
measures starrett e package so that it
would essentially reduce spending
increase revenue so forth the problem
with that is that austerity basically
leads to an even greater economic
contraction it doesn't generate growth
it generates even greater contraction
and this happened at a time when Greece
was already experiencing an economic
contraction so things got worse not
better and by the fall of 2010 it was
clear that the huge amount of debt that
Greece had would probably have to be
restructured stretched out into the
future in some way and in fact Greece
suggested that more than a year ago by
this past spring it became apparent that
Greece would need roughly 170 billion
euros between 2011 and 2014 in order to
finance itself and it had still about 50
or 60 billion leftover from last year's
package but it would still need about
100 120 billion euros more from the EU
and the IMF and that led the eurozone
countries to negotiate a new second
bailout and they did that in June and
July
it was delayed for variety of reasons
they now finally agreed on it in late
October and but we haven't had a formal
Greek approval of that bailout package
yet and we are just now literally today
getting a new government in Greece that
will presumably approve that package and
implement the measures that the eurozone
has said have to be implemented in order
to fix the long-term problem in Greece
do you think that will happen do you
think it will be fixed well I think it
will I mean we're speaking now November
tenth and just today Greece announced
that a man named Lucas Papa dimas will
take over his prime minister he's a
former European Central Bank vice
president an economist a technocrat well
that sounds non-minority help
non-political person they've had a huge
fight between the big parties and Greece
over the terms of mr. Papa dimas
transition government but I think they
will at least approve the package and
they have to approve the package in
order to get 8 billion euros between now
and December nineteenth on December
nineteenth Greece will have to repay two
billion in bonds that have matured it
doesn't have the money to do that it
needs the money what is called a tranche
a slice of the last year's bailout in
order to do that and it has in all about
eight billion do in December if it
doesn't pay that he will have to default
so and it can only get that money if it
approves the second bailout so so we're
really up against a time limit in Greece
and presumably now the government will
approve the bailout it will get the
tranche it will have enough money to
repay the
bonds that come due in December and at
least it will carry on for a while
longer okay well but meanwhile Italy
Italy yes I was going to ask you about
Italy and and Berlusconi in particular
he is stepping down or has stepped down
at this point so tell us about what's
going on there well Italy Italy has is a
much larger problem than Greece Italy
has more debt more public debt than
Greece Ireland Portugal Spain put
together Wow and huge given all of the
problems that the EU has had with Greece
as well as Portugal and Ireland which
have also had bailouts and Spain which
has been a problem Italy has more debt
in all one point nine trillion euros and
they have 300 billion euros that of debt
that they have to borrow they have to go
into the markets for 300 billion next
year in 2012 and that is a huge huge
problem do you think they're going to
solve it what's going to happen well
they've been they've been wrestling with
that problem for some time and the EU
has made it clear that Greece has to
take certain measures to try to
stimulate growth by restructuring the
economy well it has to change the
retirement age raise the retirement age
it has to you might say liberalize the
professions to allow more people into
them it needs to deal with its labor
market regulations to make it a little
easier to hire and fire all of these
things are very politically contentious
the government hasn't wanted to do that
in addition it has to raise taxes and it
has to lower spending and the government
doesn't want to do that either none of
those very popular things love Italy is
popular and so the government has been
dragging its feet and Berlusconi in
particular has been
dragging his feet even though his
finance minister has been saying we have
to do this we have to do this Berlusconi
has been dragging his feet the EU and
the ECB have been essentially telling
the Italians the Italian government what
it has to do for the last three months
and has said we won't support you in the
bond markets unless you do these things
Italy has still been dragging its feet
finally it's become so apparent that the
foot dragging has been so egregious you
might say that that finally Berlusconi
has agreed to resign he did so only
after it became clear that he had lost a
majority in his own coalition and so he
is going to resign some time according
to one of the spokesman between Saturday
and Monday which would probably mean
sunday and on Sunday the government will
vote on a financial stability act that
will do some of the things the Europeans
want Italy to do but there's still a
problem that Italy is really it's too
big to fail and it's too big to bail out
and there's no way the Europeans can
marshal enough money to stand behind one
point nine trillion of debt so there's a
real uncertainty now in the markets and
in the financial community in general
whether the eurozone can stay together
well let's talk about that what do you
think the future holds i mean there are
critics of the eurozone and the euro
should we never should they never have
gone that route to begin with or you
know if it can be saved you know how can
it be saved well i think i think they
should have gone that route to begin
with and the way to think about that is
imagine if in the u.s. we had 50
currencies of the state we had a state
dollar and a connecticut dollar an hour
dollar and rhode island dollar and and
they
had different values and we were trading
and exchanging and traveling and so
forth and we had to change our currency
every time we went out of the country
you know obviously we would say what we
really need to ease the transactions is
a single currency so given that Europe
is highly interdependent most of its
trade is with other with other members
of the European Union it makes sense to
have a euro the problem is they didn't
really have a good criteria for deciding
who should get in and who shouldn't get
in Greece has never been able to really
be competitive with the other countries
of the eurozone in terms of trade in
terms of goods and services and trade
and so forth it's never really been
competitive and they didn't really deal
with the question of how do countries
remain competitive once they lose
control over their monetary policy and
they lose control over their exchange
rate that is they can't lower interest
rates and they can't lower their
exchange rate to boost trade export it's
like a catch-22 and so how do you remain
competitive in that situation you have
to have a very good strong competitive
economy and Greece doesn't have that
Portugal doesn't have that does anyone
have that Jeremy I would imagine Germany
has that Germany has that the the
Netherlands has a number of the
countries do but Greece has been in defa
trade deficits current account deficits
every year since 1999 that you might say
that's an unobtrusive measure of of the
fact that it doesn't have a competitive
economy so what they have to do is is
recent door or create some kind of some
degree of competitiveness in the Greek
economy the Portuguese economy and to
lesser extent even the Italian economy
that's a very hard thing that has to do
with restructuring the whole economy
not just about and what if you can't do
that then what happens i mean do you
foresee any countries getting kicked out
of the euro zone well it's possible that
some might be what one of the things
that's happening now is that the
political leaders are talking about
possibly two tier or multi-tier eurozone
where there would be a core inner group
the French and the Germans have been
talking about that just in the last few
days there's also a possibility of of
the some of the eurozone countries
moving forward and and developing even
more greater integration while the other
eurozone members are faced with being on
the periphery as they are now or even
dropping out it's an interesting moment
in time because the year i think the
Europeans don't really know where
they're going at this point the general
sense of this is that they are at a fork
in the road and as Yogi Berra once said
when you get to a fork in the road you
have to take it and the fork in the road
is you might say the eurozone breaking
up okay or moving forward with more
Europe more Europe is a slogan that is
very popular in Germany Germany these
days and in other countries it means we
need more rules stronger rules more
enforcement more mechanisms to integrate
the economies but also to keep to make
sure that they stay on track and they
don't free ride you might say within the
eurozone the third but there is a third
fork in the road and it's the one the
Europeans have been on for a long time
and probably will be on for some time to
come it's the fork of muddling through
and I think that's basically what they
will do they theoretically speaking it
would make sense for Europe to push
forward more Europe develop
a greater degree of you might say
coordinated control over fiscal policy
I'm you know they seem to need some
control and and enforcers I need an
enforcer they need and they need tough
enforcement they need more coordination
they need some degree of control over
the National of the fiscal policies of
the member states at least those which
get in trouble they need to have some
kind of veto power for a country that
simply goes off the path fiscally
speaking and doesn't get correct itself
and they've been trying to invent that
as they go along over this last year and
a half but they may need a treaty change
to do that the problem to do that
effectively the problem is that there
isn't a great deal of support for a
treaty change in the EU right now
because as is always the case a treaty
change has to be approved by all of the
member states and that's very difficult
and it means in at least one country
Ireland there has to be a referendum and
there might be referendums in a number
of countries which might get result in
the treaty being defeated so it's not
clear they can go to a treaty change and
do more Europe the idea of the eurozone
breaking up i think is not an attractive
alternative for the same reasons I
mentioned earlier that they are highly
interdependent economies they need to
trade exchange goods it makes sense
logically speaking to have a single
currency so what do they do between
those two options my guess is they will
continue muddling through but the
Italian crisis in particular is one that
really has europe i think scratching its
head I mean Greece is a small problem in
the big scale of things in the European
Union to two and a half percent of the
population
roughly the same amount in terms of the
gross domestic product it's it's a
relatively small actor in the eurozone
Italy is much larger it's ten times
larger in terms of its economy and and
its weight in Europe end as I mentioned
it has a huge amount of debt yeah and I
know it's it's it's not only problematic
there but it's also affecting our stock
market to its present exactly because of
the uncertainty any other countries
teetering on the brink so to speak oh
and the eurozone who else are looking at
well there's always there's always the
danger that if somehow the Italian
problem is fixed the markets will say
what about Spain what about Belgium what
about France in fact Moody's last month
said that Fran it would look again at
France in January and decide whether it
should keep its high credit rating given
its deficit and and its problems I want
that lead france on monday to institute
quite severe austerity measures that is
cutting spending raising taxes so there
are countries in the you might say in
the sights of the financial markets
beyond italy but i think italy is really
the problem that has to be solved at
this point and and if they can resolve
some way to solve figure out some way to
solve the italian problem that
presumably would work for spain which
isn't really in as difficult situation
as italy and it might hold the markets
offer the time being all right well very
good we'll have to see how this all
works out hopefully hopefully for the
better thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work you're welcome for more information
about professor Cameron and his research
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale